[Music]
in the marvel cinematic universe the
people are protected by two separate yet
equally important groups the heroes who
save them and the attorneys who clean up
their collateral damage but only one can
be both
this is her story done done
lawyer show
she holds a legal comedy like we've
never done before
all rise
back now amen all right calm down
what's fun is the types of marvel
characters that come to her for legal
advice no judge is going to take this
seriously unless we do things by the
book oh the bulk of a chantey no the
book of american uh loss
it's the law show the galley mcpheel or
the practice
and then it breaks all those rules
the fun of the show is to combine this
legal world and all of the possibilities
around a superhero weirdness
call my lawyer
i just want to be a normal anonymous
lawyer
we're really pushing boundaries other
shows haven't before
case closed
done done
when you're a hulk trouble is going to
find you this thursday weird
unexpected trouble
let's do this seahawk culture is a total
snack
abomination
namaste walk the sorceress supreme in
madison two ends one why but it's not
where you think
just remember who show this actually is
she-hulk is streaming on disney plus
this thursday
who the hell are you jennifer walters
attorney at law
jen this is your life now whether you
like it or not trouble's gonna find you
let's do this
you could be an avenger i'm not a
superhero that is for billionaires and
narcissists
and adult orphans for some reason
she-hulk attorney at law original series
streaming august 18th only on disney
plus
[Music]
you